hey anthony i saw that head in the
clouds the kinjas were there you guys
performed there dude all red leather
jackets i was like do you guys just show
up at like the men's warehouse and be
like can i get 12 red pets
and then they're like that is all the
red pants we got you already know that
men's warehouse doesn't have that look
which one the king aesthetic where do
you guys go burlington coat factory half
and half the jackets were custom
everything else we had to put together
piece by piece but you got to get extra
large because fashion nova is like
skinny you know plus you guys are
dancing so you need some material that
has some stretching they don't really
need stretchy clothes they don't do that
much you know
so you spend hella money
you spend for us we spent a hell of
money and and resources
to put things like a custom jacket
together how is it like performing in
front of 40 000 people and 80 of people
are on drugs or just eating a hot dog
hmm yeah but i feel like you can finally
rub it in our faces and you're only in
vegas we're actually doing festivals
[ __ ] now we can